this morning i was scrolling twitter and
i saw a tweet that had me stopped in my
tracks as i was scrolling through here's
the tweet that i saw turkey is fighting
consumer price inflation by having
authorities go to supermarkets check
prices and threaten fines if the prices
are too high i literally couldn't
believe this so of course everyone knows
that turkey is experiencing incredibly
high inflation right now the estimations
for december is that inflation is going
to come in at a 30
year-over-year change that is insane the
estimations are anywhere between 26 to
37 and the average of all the economists
together is 30 here in the united states
we have almost 7 percent and people are
freaking the hell out imagine if we had
30 well that is what the turkish
citizens and business owners are dealing
with but to add salt to the wound here
is what the local authorities are doing
this is a video that they released
themselves and i'll read to you in a
minute what exactly the tweet says in
translation but let's watch the video
first the local authorities released
this and they are proud of what they are
doing here
this is the authorities
in the grocery store
talking to the grocery store owners
about what the prices of the goods and
services actually are
they not only are
talking to them
they not only
are lecturing them
but they are even going as far as doling
out fines and you'll see they're
scanning prices and they're writing them
down to come back later and check to see
what is the actual increase
and here it goes the crazy part where
you start to see them actually checking
item by items of what the prices are
every single item must be checked must
be written down
it's not just pen and paper
scanning
is that price gouging is a common claim
when high inflation happens governments
step in and they start yelling and
screaming at the business owners and
saying oh it's not the undisciplined
monetary and fiscal policy decisions
we've made instead it is simply that
these business owners are taking
advantage of you but grocery stores
operate on razor thin margins usually
less than five percent profit margins
it's not like in 2021 they just decided
you know what this is the year i'm gonna
price gouge no of course not they have
material costs that are going up the
supply chain is forcing their costs up
and their labor costs are going up as
well it's all tied back to inflation and
so whether they're going to either
operate at a loss or they're going to
increase their prices and pass on those
higher costs to the customer of course
they're going to increase the prices and
so ultimately when you have government
starting to intervene in the market
whether they're implementing some sort
of price control like in turkey or
they're implementing capital controls
where investors can't actually take
their money out of a currency it simply
exasperates the problem so when i see
this video all it tells me is that we
haven't learned from history it is
insane to think of the local police or
local authorities going grocery store by
grocery store by grocery store and
checking every single item to see what
the price is how much it's increased
over time and then issuing fines if you
increase it too much i don't know about
you but i would much rather have
entrepreneurs and business owners
running these businesses than the
government and the local police the
local police was so good at running
businesses maybe they shouldn't be
police officers and instead they should
own businesses but until that day comes
let's leave the businesses to the
business owners and let's leave the
policing to the police